bentornati nel canale che se non prende
per il culo qualcuno non è contento e si
è perché il vino dell'altra volta è
stato molto apprezzato dalla gente ma
per i motivi sbagliati
ci sono tutti impettiti tutti incazzati
col dito giudice e blogger sono la
rovina di youtube italia quando in
realtà il mio punto era tutt'altro ma
ormai ci ho fatto l'abitudine al
pubblico su internet piace vedere la
gente che si scanna tra di loro cade
conto che il mostarda su fuga di
cervelli è stato il primo video a
raggiungere le due milioni di views
tutto nella norma ma oggi siamo qui per
la seconda parte ovvero le challenge
perché se queste persone possono
rincoglionirsi davanti alla telecamera
per il giubilo del pubblico cazzo lo
posso fare anch'io maestro faccia
partire il sottofondo poco eterosessuale
ma molto molto fastidiosi che usano
tutti i miei blog perché è gratuito su
youtube
siamo finalmente pronti per iniziare e
ragazzi grazie grazie veramente di cuore
perché tutte queste challenge
io le faccio per voi solo ed
esclusivamente per voi non perché sono
vivi su facili non perché ci voglia un
cazzo aggirarle un cazzo montane non è
per quello
lo faccio perché siete i miei iscritti e
siete i migliori del mondo
una piccola cosuccia soltanto se potete
farvi un bidet prima di iniziare a
guardare i miei video perché quando puoi
dire qualcuno è un macello e mi
raccomando se nei commenti volete
lasciarvi un suggerimento usate sempre
l'ashtag usatelo perché altrimenti non
riusciremo ad infestare anche qui per
quindi mi raccomando usate l'ashtag
prostata e adesso andiamoci sotto di
challenge partiamo con la prima roulette
russa challenge non sai cos'è una
roulette russa
beh è un gioco che fanno i grandi quindi
bambino o bambina che stai guardando
questo video invece di studiare farti
una cultura anna per tutti quelli che
sono rimasti invece partirei con la
challenge dal mio cameraman ieri di qua
ti è andata bene ragazzi lo faccio per
voi momento però le risorse bassissime
così mi serve qualcos'altro da fare oggi
faremo la rischia al gusto challenge con
la spazzatura
vediamo cosa riusciamo a trovare la
discografia completa degli one direction
anche se non li ho mai ascoltati gli
odio perché lo dice internet quindi
perfetti per la nostra challenge neanche
adesso con la gente abituata veramente
allo schifo
benvenuti nella challenge e fa il make
up ad un tuo amico anche se sei
eterosessuale
e siccome queste challenger si fanno in
cui ho voluto chiamare un amico youtuber
ovviamente anche lui ha un sacco di
iscritti altrimenti non servirebbe un
cazzo fare questi video guglielmo non
amava farlo challenge lui quindi avuto
in qualche modo è tra l'altro così non
possiamo manco farla la challenge del
micam ci sono hashtag necrofilia
challenge tagli e guglielmo che facciamo
il botto qui
daje cazzo 500.000 iscritti finalmente
adesso manca soltanto una cosa e siamo a
posto
no no voi non avete capito niente voi
non avete capito niente
io questa cosa qua la voglio fatta
adesso oggi all'istante valore di fare
no no lo sai perché
lo sai perché perché se non lo fate oggi
non faccio spezzani candidati amici di
mio padre perché lo sai per chi lavora
mio padre
adesso sì che te lo ricordi e adesso
no non domani oggi voi questa cosa la
dovete fare oggi gli hanno dato il
verificato di twitter ragazzi questi
obiettivi li ho fatti grazie a voi vi
giuro che ci metto passione in quello
che faccio i complimenti quindi è questo
quello che fai adesso con il tuo canale
non ho idea di cosa cazzo stia
succedendo sono la tua coscienza
imbecille cosa che aspettavi un
armadillo no volevo solo sapere una cosa
volevo sapere quando è stata l'ultima
volta che tu invece hai fatto un video
decente quando è stato le tue ultime
recensioni i primi mostarda gli ultimi
mostarda
no dai veramente di meno perché io non
me lo ricordo e non solo tu parlo di
tutti i big di youtube quando è stata
l'ultima volta che c'è stato veramente
un video decente su youtube italia se
quasi alla soglia del milione e ti metti
a di risultare altri canali piccoli che
non c'entrano niente con il tuo è questo
che vuoi fare allora in avanti o magari
farei altre promesse tipo che a
settembre riprenderei con i video melli
sinceramente romeno mi ricordo neanche
quando è stata l'ultima volta che hai
fatto video dei 100 ma questo lo sai
anche tu solo che se intoccabile to save
yotobi quello che ha creato youtube
italia manco fossi pippo baudo ma se
vuoi sentire un consiglio spassionato
detto da uno che vive con te da 27 anni
più voli in alto e più rumore fai quando
cadi